with great power comes great
responsibility and how you handle that
responsibility says everything about
your skill set as a leader at least 13
of our service members were killed in
yesterday's terror attack on the airport
while hundreds of desperate americans
are still trying to flee afghanistan our
commander in chief
says he takes full responsibility but
not really time to blame trump
i bear responsibility for
fundamentally all that's happened
of late but here's the deal
you know i wish you one day say these
things you know as well as i do
that a former president
made a deal with the taliban
that he would get all american forces
out of afghanistan by may 1.
pointing the finger at somebody else
while claiming responsibility is
something democrats do well
but no one not even uncle joe can do it
better than hillary clinton remember her
as i have said many times since
september 11th i take responsibility
when i took responsibility i took it as
a challenge you know look i take
responsibility you haven't actually that
you haven't taken enough of the blame on
yourself because again that was
something which came up in the campaign
that you know oh hillary tries to blame
other people and not herself and do you
accept this criticism that you know
bernie sanders no i don't
and we thought that was bad joining me
now is someone who knows what it really
means to be a leader veteran navy seal
an author of leadership strategy and
tactics
jocko willing so jocko when you hear
someone say i take responsibility and
then they say the word but
no
that's a red flag what would you have
liked the president to have said this
week
well as you just pointed out
when you take ownership of something you
cannot follow it with the word but
especially when you are the president of
the united states and you are literally
responsible for everything that happens
so you have to take ownership of it take
responsibility for it and then you
actually have to put a plan into action
to solve the problem that has been
created by you that's what we need to
see from the president right now
his method is empathy they're trying to
say
i feel your pain
and even though i caused that pain
that's going to absolve me of any
accountability for it
that seems to fly in politics but when
you're the commander-in-chief
the head of the military
i don't think that cuts it
i think he's saying a bunch of words
right now that are having less and less
meaning every day i mean he made this
this statement that we will not forgive
we will not forget we will hunt you down
and make you pay
and in the meantime we are following the
orders of the taliban and they want us
out of there by august 31st so that's
when we're leaving
it doesn't it doesn't match up his
actions aren't matching his words his
words are becoming more and more weak
every single day
we ran with kellogg the guy that did the
deal under trump with the taliban
and he said last night he said these
this date could have been moved it was
not set in stone and there were four
conditions that had to be met and
the trump plan was to keep bagram and to
keep 2 500 american forces there and
paramilitary back guys from the cia
there
until
everybody was out and all the weaponry
was out and
biden just blew it up set an arbitrary
date with no conditions and it was
helter skelter
and now we are trying to attempt to
negotiate with a complete position of
weakness and we should never do that we
should always negotiate from a position
of strength especially because we're the
united states of america the strongest
and most powerful military in the world
all right giaco willik everybody go
check out the podcast then go check out
the book i read the book
and now i don't blame the producers for
anything i just own all the mistakes
that they make and they love that thanks
chaka
outstanding hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else